this is Startalk all right um okay so we
got one more one more before we break
all right this is from Rob Z what do you
think the bright spot on saris is a
serious serious yes so the the largest
asteroid is actually has enough gravity
to turn it into a round shape so it's
the only round asteroid technically we
shouldn't even call it an asteroid is it
a level to dwarf planet there precisely
no oh I bet hang around Utah oh I've
been around you hips it mom so objects
that are that are just big enough to be
turned into a sphere by their own
gravity right but they haven't cleared
their orbit because Sirius is orbiting
in the asteroid belt dwarf planet Pluto
okay big enough to be a sphere but it's
orbiting in the Kuiper belt dwarf planet
guys so so a bright spot on Ceres I have
no idea tell you all this stuff about
Sirius through the first asteroid
discovered back in 1880 no one van so
obviously going to discover the biggest
brightest one first right real could
that makes sense and they wanted to they
thought they discovered a planet and so
they want and planets are named after
Roman gods God and so they named it
after Roman Roman goddess of harvest and
Ceres that's the root of the word cereal
right mmm whole grain oh man that's
delicious a delicious plant oh that or
dwarf planet so that series so nice I'm
guessing it's a highly reflective icy
area right of it of the object because
ice can be very reflective relative to
any other kind of rock that and doesn't
take much to be more reflective than
rock to show up blazingly in images you
take of an object that's yeah so that's
my guess
well there you go rob get yourself a
bowl and a spoon and enjoy some series
this is Startalk